in three words describe the peacemaker
to me
i need one more okay four words then so
as far as
suicide squad and maker goes these are
my four words
you are not ready okay so let me just
jump right in because um when i got the
trailer yesterday i knew i only had like
i felt like i was in the fast and
furious it's like you only have 90
minutes to watch this thing and then it
goes away
so i just kept watching it over and over
again and i was like holy smokes
just when you think they can't get more
over the top then i get magnets
i get flying cars i get all kinds of
crazy stuff
how blown away by this were you when you
like just got to sit down and kind of
watch this
play out besides shooting it well i mean
f9 delivers that's that's the only
that's the only way to say it
you always say never turn your back on
family
but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
you know okay so the last time i talked
to you about this was at january super
bowl of 2020
and you were being very coy about being
dom's brother and kind of what that
would bring
and the fight scenes with you and ben
look bananas
i mean did everybody go home with
bruises at the end of the night or how
did that work for you guys
well uh filming a fight scene in the
movies is much different than wwe wwe
once and you're done and movies they
have to be meticulous with the angles
and the preparation
and then fighting dom toretto
in the fast and the furious is like
being
in the main event of wrestlemania you
get thrust in there with a
marquee talent on a blockbuster
franchise you're on the main stage in
the grandest stage of them all
you have to deliver and i know i i know
what that feeling of being the last
match in wrestlemania is like
and i knew what i was getting into
serving certainly when i signed up as
jacob
it wasn't easy it was but it was very
demanding and very intense but
uh the product speaks for itself and i
think i think
fans are asking the question about jacob
and wondering about the storyline and
certainly wondering about
those confrontations and i can promise
you f9 delivers
and i'm wondering about the answer to
the question that charlize asked when
she says but can you kill him
talking about your brother because we
don't get that answer
so i think there's a lot of interesting
things there especially
uh charlize's involvement and services
certainly returned to the franchise
and dom toretto i think the theme here
is don toretto
finally after eight installments facing
the one thing that he never can and
that's his past
the question may not be if given the
opportunity will i kill him
it's will dom face his past or will he
continue to run away
love that it don't matter if you win by
an inch or a mile
that's right winning's winning
so this year you know mark's the 20th
anniversary of the franchise the first
film was 2001.
so what does that mean to you number one
celebrate 20 years of the franchise this
year and then with you
joining this cast well certainly
literally it's the opportunity of a
lifetime
it doesn't happen without finn and it's
amazing to see that he still is the
heart and soul of the franchise after 20
years
there's very few titles that can say
that they've
held box office success for so long uh
with the same formula embracing
diversity and
family and delivering over-the-top
action
um it really is an opportunity of a
lifetime this this is a life-changing
experience for me
and i was invited into the success
i understand that the main players of
the franchise
started from the foundation and built
this tremendous
platform and i'm i'm gracious to be
invited in and i did not take that life
i love that so much now after this you
know you have the peacemaker so
in three words describe the peacemaker
to me
i need one more okay four words then so
as far as
suicide squad and maker goes these are
my four words
you are not ready
i love when you do that you gotta be
kidding me you're gonna risk the entire
mission for a mental defective dress as
a court justice it's coming from a guy
that wears a toilet seat on his head
you do it you give that tease better
than just about anybody for sure
and and and you're also getting your own
spin-off right for peacemaker so how
does it feel to be
one of the first leading the pack now
for this next evolution of what
dc is trying to do well i think it
speaks volumes to the fact that dc
is avidly listening to its fans and
really taking chances on expanding its
universe as we know black atom is
underway and that certainly will be a
wonderful nucleus
for the temple of dc uh restructuring
and moving forward
they're they're making a huge play to
try to satisfy a world full of fans out
there
and i'm i'm really fortunate to be a
part of that i know we got
we got something real different for
everybody so
very excited to be a part of that as
well and i think you know
judging from initial response the
trailer was viewed 151 million times in
a very
very short period of time breaking the
all-time record for
redband trailer views so i think that
says that people are really interested
and i just hope we can deliver